he might be the only man on planet Earth
to be in a movie with Kevin Durant and
Kate Winslet but that's the range that
this man has he is Jim Belushi
as for the Kate Winslet film it's in
theaters near you right now called
Wonder Wheel Jim Belushi good to see you
nice to see you how's that for now that
was that was cool then a little
basketball movie you're talking about
yeah yeah yeah it's a cute movie what
was the rant like under struck right
yeah thunder starring you was sweet it
was nice she was 21 I think you turned
21
on the set yeah yeah he was fine she had
like a birthday yeah and then now he's a
look at him now I mean he's like one of
the all-time greats Kevin Durant is an
all-time great are you kidding me it was
all time great done nobody can really
show herself now yeah and um so now
you're a Chicago guy as we know if I
ought to give you one guy in the history
of Chicago sports that you would say
this guy represents this town it doesn't
matter okay okay what do you got for any
banks I mean let's play to over Jordan
over you know you know Jordan was a
Chicago player but he was everybody's
player you know I mean he was a national
player everybody loves Jordan and
everybody took pride in him and he's the
greatest
and he brought great pride to Chicago
but the essence of the working man and
the essence of the heart of Chicago is
Ernie Banks always a thing I mean did go
I mean he's Chicago Jordan but yeah I
mean the sweetness to write everything
was right there yeah Ernie Banks hurry
man let's play - did you ever meet him
oh yes couple times what do you got for
me he's just very chatty very lovely
he's got a great spirit and always
positive and right you know he can play
through any any trouble he was I met him
one time yeah okay I'll tell you the
story hello this is it I'm with my
girlfriend at the time who is now my
wife okay okay
Kludd my girlfriend at the time okay and
we were because she was covering the
angels for Fox Sports and I was covering
spring training for ESPN and we met in
Phoenix oh boy yeah
and so we're it I think like the
phoenicians hotel he has a driving range
yes baseball's my issue is my wife me
and then up comes walking Ernie Banks oh
no I mean on the driving range and I'm
we went over to him to say hello to him
and he goes you guys have kids yet and
we're like no no we're we're you know
we're just dating starts telling us how
we have to get married and must have
children we just need to play one that's
pressure Ernie what are you doing but he
was just a huge dude like a human being
like on planet earth yes and and and he
he really does he really does capture
the spirit I mean dick oh really you
know we you know we go he got us a Super
Bowl brightening of feels to me that we
won the Super Bowl three years ago you
know but it was you know 30 years ago
almost it is amazing how long it's been
it's been a long time but you know as a
Cubs fan
we waited 108 years so that's nothing as
long as we got one as long as we got one
I could carry myself with pride in any
city yeah I was about to say Jim Belushi
here in the Rich Eisen show and we'll
talk Wonder Wheel in a second what did
that championship mean to you the Cubs
championship mean to you it meant that
anything can happen if the Cubs can one
win the World Series I can do a movie
with Woody Allen just it was the most
beautiful thing in the world you know it
it was a very tense time and ricketts
the very interesting he the owner easy
owner Tom Riggins the owner and he I
talked to him one time he said you know
Jim during the day
during the ball game I go and walk
through the crowd since I'm a new owner
and I sit down on a piece seats and I
talked to the fans to get to know them
and I do it all the time because you
know what the number one question is I
get I said what do how old do you think
I am you know obviously we're gonna win
the World Series in your life that's
uncle my poor uncle Dino he passed away
in September before the Cubs series a
year month before I was so sad and he
was in his bed no you know what the
visit on that knee goes wow this is the
year they're gonna jump they're gonna
choke is real Cubs fan forever but he
did pass away with nothing comes to one
in the World Series so now what does it
mean to me hmm
bears won a Superbowl Cubs won the World
Series I could go anytime that's it now
I know and you sang Sweet Home Chicago
at the at the at Wrigley during I think
an NLCS game yes yeah come on baby don't
you did you ever meet Harry Caray many
times
maneet I know or any circumstances that
you can well he was just lovely and some
things you know here and there but he
was always lovely to me you know Jack
Brickhouse way back as a Great Dane you
know Cecotto baseball when Jimmy Belushi
comes up to the booth how are you Jimmy
vodka no Irina vodka that sounds like it
yeah was your brother into this as much
was John into the cub you know what I he
got me into the Cubs because I've told
this to Bob Newhart Obama numerous big
Chicago Cubs fan yeah and when my
brother John was very young he went to
the ball game and he got Bob Newhart's
autograph on a popcorn box at Wrigley at
really feels Bob was so sweet to John
and John came home so excited and I was
like wow magic can happen in Wrigley
Field I want to go I don't want to go
and that's how it your your Wrigley
fandom in a way got sparks all right
through bob newhart and your brother and
my brother and and Jack Brickhouse you
know they have a great marketing tool
there you know they give free tickets to
Cub Scouts and Girl Scouts and
organizations and our Cub Scout den 7 we
had free tickets to Wrigley Field and we
all went and sure enough Jack Brickhouse
goes it's a great day at Wrigley Field
in Chicago Cubs when den 7 from Wheaton
Illinois comes to the book and all of a
sudden we were stars so yeah magic can
happen in Wrigley Field and magic
happened we won the World Series Jim
Belushi here on the Rich Eisen show all
right tell me about Wonder Wheel here
Kate Winslet Justin Timberlake Juno
Temple and you essentially carry the
film here oh it's Kate's film she is
just terrific in this film and I'm
fortunate to be in it and Woody Allen
selected me it was it was a big deal on
itself
I mean woody is a tour artist of it
highest level and was like I said was an
honor to be in at the movie is like a
play I mean it is it feels it takes
place in 1950s it feels like a Tennessee
Williams play or an Arthur Miller play
it's very dramatic and very performance
orientated and Kate is just beautiful in
it and it's probably the best work I've
done it no kidding yeah well that's
that's awesome
and you play you play ad Humpty that's
his name on T and you rot you run the
carousel in Coney Island and she is the
L works in the oyster bar at Coney
Island we're you know flat broke and she
lost her husband and I lost my wife and
it was a terrific tragedies for both of
us and we kind of found each other I
always feel in a bar you know on the
floor blackout drunk and we kind of
saved each other and then my daughter
comes back Karolina
mmm that beautiful girl he saw there and
she was married to a mobster and she
turned over a state's out Peninsula so
she's hiding out with me and it changes
the Wonder Wheel yes the wheel changes
and
then there's lots of trauma after that
very very good it's in select theaters
near you right now and you know I mean
when you talk about some of the
directors that you have worked with okay
and you know some of them just jump out
at me because I'm a big pop culture
freak John Hughes being one and curly
sue what was it like working with John
Hughes John was uh he's a very gifted
writer director I was a very talented
man and very challenging on the set
which brings out great performances but
he was really great for Chicago he
brought all his movies to Chicago put a
lot of people to work in Chicago
including me right so he's another
Chicago icon there with the the Jordans
and everybody else right so it's Mamet -
you could say - right David Mamet about
last night last night isn't a great film
that was that was the one I you know I
did the stage play in Chicago and then
Don Simpson from Paramount came and saw
the play and he said to me you should
write a screenplay on this so I told the
producers what he said and they got
really excited very naively and they
wrote a script and so I gave it to Don
and he loved it and two weeks later I
get a call from my brother John and he
goes uh Simpson just offered me and
Danny the roles in sexual perversity in
Chicago which was about last night
mm-hmm
and I said well don't do it cuz aw come
on Jim you don't understand Hollywood
they're heat-seeking missiles Danny and
I are hot they're gonna give it to me
and Dana they're not gonna give it to
you you're still a kid in Chicago I said
don't do it John
that's just my role I developed it on
stage it says this is my puppy I can't I
can't eat a cheeseburger I can't lift
the sword I hit Harvey I mean uh Henry
Kissinger like you've sucked everything
up Marlon Brando this is my role leave
it alone he goes Jimmy if I pass on it
they're gonna offer it to Billy Murray
now wouldn't you rather have someone in
your family I said don't do it yeah you
don't understand how they wouldn't he
hung up well sure enough John and Danny
passed and bill
we passed I think John might have had a
little something to do with it no
kidding yeah and then they wanted to
turn around and Tristar picked it up and
I got the role and I was - that was the
the movie the role of my career changed
my life and now I'm in you great in it
and it lasts today I mean you've been in
Steven and some the remote drop movies
like one of that one in trading places
in the end they're on the train partying
what was that like being on that set
that was a great set because I was like
very young actor at the time at 1983
yeah yeah and I was it was great because
that there was a lot of snow storms that
happened that month I was only supposed
to work for a week in the end of the
working for a month and so I made a lot
of money and it was a lot of fun and you
know and he was doing good and I just
got on Saturday Night Live it was it was
it was a good time a good time but I
worked with Michael Mann and thief the
first year we've got that in Chicago
that's 1981 yeah then Oliver Stone and
Salvador and I just worked with Polanski
now Woody Allen it's just been a been a
lovely career I've been having a nice
time yeah David Lynch - it's nuts like I
mean oh my gosh I surprised Wonder Wheel
and select theaters and theaters near
you it started just earlier this month
Amazon Studios film Wonder Wheel with
you Jim Belushi come back anytime sir
thank you so much that's a fun you got
it the Rich Eisen show weekdays at noon
eastern on audience